Die zwei Sprechstunden. Und damit herzlich willkommen zum Chaos Radio im Blue Moon. Dem Blue Moon, wo alle zwei Monate der Chaos Computer Club zu Fritz kommt und das Studio besetzt und dann Dinge erzählt über das komische Internet oder diese seltsame Digitaltechnologie, die mittlerweile so alltäglich für uns geworden ist, dass wir gar nicht mehr darüber nachdenken, dass das irgendwie was extra oder Besonderes sein könnte. Und heute soll es ums Internet gehen, also genauer genommen, was da ganz weit oben passiert, weil was man nicht weiß, ist, dass Internet besteht oder funktioniert, so wie es funktioniert, vor allem deshalb, weil da unglaublich viele Regeln bestehen. Also es ist schon auch ganz viel Technik, aber es ist auch so, dass da ganz viel geregelt werden muss. Da tun die Leute zusammen und erfinden Dinge, wie Datenverkehr gelenkt wird, wo der überhaupt ankommt, wie man den austauscht und lauter fürchterliche Sachen. Wir haben das von der anderen Seite schon mal versucht, anzugehen im Chaosradio 182. Da wurde erklärt, was eigentlich passiert, wenn man da sozusagen das Routerkabel in die Wand steckt und was dann direkt dahinter passiert. Und heute gehen wir quasi an die andere Seite, ganz nach oben, um mal zu gucken, wer bestimmt eigentlich, wie das Internet funktioniert und was für Konsequenzen hat das für uns. Dazu sind im Studio Clemens. Hallo, hallo. Und Mutags, hallo, hallo.
Später sollen alle so angefragten Dokumente in einer Online-Bibliothek für die Öffentlichkeit verfügbar gemacht werden.
Wer also wissen will, ob ein vereinfachter Zugang zum Medizinstudium dem Gesundheitssystem helfen würde oder wie sich die Abgeordneten das komplexe Steuersystem erklären lassen, kann auf fragdenstaat.de oder frag den Bundestag all das jetzt nachlesen oder einfach über die Website selber anfragen. Bei der VBB-Fahrkarte wurden trotz gegenteiliger Angaben in den Broschüren des VBB offenbar doch eindeutige Standort-Ides beim Benutzen der Karte gespeichert, sodass sich Bewegungsprofile der Benutzer erstellen lassen. Besonders brisant, ein normales Mobiltelefon reicht, um den Karteninhalt auszulesen, auch bei fremden oder geteilten Karten. Der VBB spricht von einem Fehler des Lieferanten und hat die Entwärter in den Bussen und Bahnen bis auf Weiteres abgeschaltet. Man habe sich auf die Aussage des Herstellers verlassen, dass eine Profilbildung nicht möglich sei. Vielen Dank, Emily Ulbricht, für die Nerd-News und ein fast unverlehentliches Studio. Wie dramatisch. Wir machen gleich weiter hier beim Chaosradio vor, aber broke for free mit My Luck. So ist das, wenn man Musik aus dem Internet runterlegt. Auf einmal ist sie zu Ende, obwohl sie eigentlich noch läuft. Was kann der Künstler damit sagen, dass er zwei Minuten still an diesem Track dran gemacht hat? Wir wissen es nicht. Herzlich willkommen zurück im Chaos Radio im Blue Moon, wo wir heute besprechen wollen, wer eigentlich die Leute sind, die weißen alten Männer und Frauen, die hinter den Kulissen des Internets sitzen und dort beschließen, wie das Ganze funktioniert. Dazu sind Clemens und Montags zu Gast. Hallo und guten Abend nochmal.
Nachbint, Mahlzeit.
Und außerdem haben wir noch den Alex zugeschaltet. Hallo, schönen guten Abend. So, weil wir haben jetzt in der ersten Stunde geklärt, was das IETF ist. Das ist ein Gremium, bei dem jeder mitmachen kann, das beschließt, wie die Standards im Internet sind. Das heißt, ganz grob gesagt, bitte nicht schlagen, falls das nicht ganz korrekt ist, wie Dinge, Computer, Protokolle, technische Angelegenheiten miteinander reden. So, und dann gibt es ja im Internet sozusagen noch zwei wichtige Dinge, nämlich die Adressen und die Nummern, die dahinter stecken. Das ist also einmal sozusagen die Domains, also, keine Ahnung, fritz.de. Die Namen. Die Namen. Und dann sozusagen werden die, wie heißt es, aufgelöst auf eine IP-Adresse. Und jetzt würde ich ja, ich weiß nicht, ob sagen, wenn jetzt hier noch jemand zuhört und denkt so IP-Adressen, ich habe immer nicht genau verstanden, was das ist. Montags. Kannst du mal erklären, was eine IP-Adresse ist?
Ich kann es versuchen. Zum einen versucht es, eine Struktur hinzubekommen, dass man von der Adresse sehen kann, wo der Rechner ist. Aber ich fange mal vorne an. Also wenn ich jetzt auf eine Webseite zugreifen möchte, von mir aus Google oder Facebook oder Fritz.de, dann kann so ein Rechner mit so einem Namen Fritz.de erstmal nicht viel anfangen. Weil in so einer großen Tabelle nachzugucken, das würde einfach zu lange dauern, die Daten zu durchsuchen. Und damit das ganze im Internet mit dem Routing einfacher geht, sprich damit ich weiß, von wo nach wo ich Pakete weiterleiten muss, wenn nichts anderes passiert, wenn ich auf eine Webseite zugreifen möchte, ich mache so einen Request, der wird in ein Paket verschickt oder in einem Datenpaket verschickt an den Server von Fritz.de. Und dazu brauche ich eine IP-Adresse. Das heißt jeder Rechner, der im Internet erreichbar sein soll, braucht eine eindeutige, nur einmal vorhandene numerische Adresse. Und bei IPv4 sieht man das, dass die irgendwie so aus drei, aus vier Oktets besteht. Zum Beispiel so eine private Adresse, wie man sie zu Hause hat, ist so 192.168.0.5 oder so was. Aber es gibt auch öffentliche IP-Adressen, das ist dann so was wie 8.8.8.8 oder 130.149.17.5. Das ist zum Beispiel eine von der TU Berlin und das erkennt man daran, dass die mit 130.149 anfängt. Diese IP-Adressen, alle die mit 130.149 anfangen, gehören zur TU Berlin, weil die TU Berlin hat unter anderem ein sogenanntes Slash-16-Netzwerk. Das heißt...
Okay, jetzt hast du alle verloren.
Genau.
Der Anfang war wirklich sehr verständlich. Aber was hast du die letzten zwei Minuten geredet?
Ich kann diese IP-Adressen aufteilen, die sind mit Punkten getrennt. Und nach bestimmten Regeln kann ich Unter-Adressräume, also Unter-Bereiche, daraus schneiden. Und so ein Slash 16 zum Beispiel ist genau die Hälfte von dieser Quotation.
Slash 16, was soll denn das heißen?
So eine IP-Adresse besteht aus vier Zahlen. Jeder dieser Zahlen hat 8 Bit und das macht insgesamt 32 Bit. Das heißt, ich habe viermal 8 Bit, 130 Punkten.
Das wird zu kompliziert.
Vor allen Dingen ist das auch e-outdated.
Nein, in dem Fall ja.
Also nicht über Dinge diskutieren, die man nicht erklären kann und dann noch sagen, man kann es.
Also ich kann die unterteilen.
Warte, ganz kurz. Es gibt also so eine IP-Adresse. Das ist also eine lange Zahl, die durch Punkte getrennt ist und aus vier einzelnen Blöcken besteht.
Bei IPv4?
Okay, und wenn man sich mal angucken will, wie man selber im Internet ist, kann man zum Beispiel auf geo.iptool.com gehen, da wird das angezeigt, die eigene IP-Adresse angezeigt. So und wenn man diese vier Zahlen kann man quasi unterteilen und wenn ich es richtig verstanden habe, je weiter vorne die Zahl, desto allgemeiner.
Das ist unruhbar, ist das.
Wenn es eine Adresse wäre, wäre ganz vorne sozusagen die Stadt. Dann käme die Straße und dann, naja, aber es wird halt immer feiner nach hinten. Okay, das heißt sozusagen, du sagst, wenn man der Anfang, sozusagen der Anfang, eine Nummer, die am Anfang steht, eine bestimmte Nummer, kann für was stehen, zum Beispiel für die TU.
Genau, 130.49 wäre die TU Berlin. Das heißt, ich weiß schon mal, dass alle diese Rechner, die hinter diesen IP-Adressen, die mit dieser Zahl anfangen sind, an der TU Berlin stehen. Das heißt, in diese Richtung muss ich meine IP-Pakete weiterleiten. Und jeder Router hat eine Tabelle, wo das eben drin steht, welche Adressanfänge, also welche Präfixe, so heißt das, er wohin routen soll. Und er erkennt anhand dieses Beginns und eben dieser Slash 16, die ich vorhin gesagt habe, das ist die Länge von diesem Bereich, wohin er das routen muss. Das heißt, das ist so was wie so ein Straßenverzeichnis im Prinzip. Ich kann ein Straßenverzeichnis nachschlagen und bekomme den Planquadraten A23 auf der Karte, weil es deswegen, wo ich dann mein Paket hinschicken muss.
Natürlich, dann weiß ich es ganz genau. So, und jetzt gibt es aber ein weiteres Gremium, was irgendwie mit diesen IP-Adressen zu tun hat. Das ist RIPE. Richtig?
Genau, RIPE wäre ein Gremium, das hier so in der europäisch, Europa...
Europa, Nordamerika, also Europa, Mittelmeer, Mittelmeer, Andereinerstaaten und Nahost.
Deswegen haben wir auch Alex in der Leitung, oder? Alex, erklär doch mal, was das RIPE ist.
Das RIPE selber ist eigentlich ein Losatzen am Schluss von Menschen, die die Regeln für die Adressvergabe in Europa, Großraum Europa, bestimmen. Und dahinter oder die beschließen praktisch die Regeln für das RIPE NCC. Da liegen sie sehr, sehr drauf, dass das getrennt wird. Das RIPE NCC ist eigentlich ein Verein in den Niederlanden, genauer in Amsterdam. Und der beugt sich sozusagen dem Beschlüssen der RIPE Community.
Und was genau machen die dann? Das heißt, wenn ich hingehe und sage, ich brauche eine IP-Adresse fürs Internet, dann verteilen die die oder was genau passiert ist?
Ja genau, erstmal lachen sie, wenn du sagst, du willst eine IPv4-Adresse haben.
Okay, Leute, können wir uns bitte darauf einigen, dass dieser ganze Komplex heute eine Nummer zu kompliziert ist und dass wir einfach dabei bleiben, es gibt IP-Adressen und die müssen verteilt werden. Okay, ganz einfach.
Also du möchtest jetzt am Internet teilnehmen, brauchst IP-Adressen, dann gehst du zur RIPE NCC und du bist dort Mitglied. Wie gesagt, das ist ein Verein. Dann zahlst du deine Aufnahmegebühr, dann wirst du Mitglied und dann hast du die Möglichkeit, Adressen zu beantragen.
Warte, da muss ich gleich nochmal nachfragen. Die beim IETF haben ja gelernt, da kann halt jeder mitmachen. Jetzt sagst du ja Aufnahmegebühr, ist das so eine symbolische Aufnahmegebühr? Oder ist das so, legen sie 5000 Euro auf den Tisch, wenn sie mitmachen wollen?
Wenn ich IP-Adressen haben möchte, also nicht bei den Regeln bestimmt, du hast ja gefragt IP-Adressen. Dann geh ich hin, leg da 2000 Euro auf den Tisch, für den Mitglied, und dann gibt es noch so eine Jahresgebühr, die wird irgendwie fertig, die musst du auch noch bezahlen. Aber dann kannst du halt hingehen und sagen, ich brauche IP-Adressen, dann gucken sie in den Regeln nach. Die Regeln macht nämlich diese Community, ähnlich wie das beschrieben wurde fürs EETF. Das heißt, wenn wir über Meldung müssten, dann besprochen, okay, wir vergeben die IP-Adressen nach folgenden Regeln. Dann gibt es eine Diskussion darüber, dann streiten sich die Kampffiele oder streiten sich auch nicht, sind sich einig. Am Ende gibt es auch wieder Working Group Shares, die so ein bisschen aufpassen, dass die Leute sich benehmen und dass das nicht unfreundlich wird.
Wird von der Regel auch nicht, aber falls doch, streiten die ein.
Und dann sagen die, okay, ich entnehme der Diskussion folgendes Meinungsbild.
Und dann wird daraus am Ende ein Regularium, wie Adressen zum Beispiel vergeben werden.
Und wenn du Adressen beantragst, dann gucken die heute mit diesem Beschluss der Gemeinschaft rein und sagen, okay, ja, du kriegst jetzt noch Adressen.
Ah, ich frage mich jetzt gerade, wie man überhaupt, also worüber dann diskutiert, also was sind denn da Streitfälle?
Zum Beispiel die Situation, die wir mit den älteren IP-Adressen haben, also IPv4-Adressen haben, die sind jetzt langsam am Ende. Also es gibt mathematisch gesehen eine gewisse Menge an IP-Adressen. Die wurden jetzt verteilt zum größten Teil.
Und dann gab es natürlich Firmen, die gesagt haben, ich will jetzt noch ein paar IP-Adressen haben.
Andere haben gesagt, oh, den müssen wir kasselhaft oder IP-Adressen üblich lassen für neue Firmen, die ganz coole Ideen haben. Und dann gibt es riesige Diskussionen darüber, nach welchen Regeln wird entschieden, wer wie viele IP-Adressen jetzt bekommt. Ob das neue Mitglieder sind, ob das alte Mitglieder sind. Also wie viele IP-Adressen kriegt derjenige? Und da wird schon sehr intensiv diskutiert, was ich meine.
Okay, und gibt es einen richtig handfesten Streit, ist das nur so, ich will aber auch drei IP-Adressen, nein, gib sie mir. Oder hat das wirklich ernsthafte Konsequenzen?
Na ja, was heißt ernsthafte Konsequenzen?
Also wenn ich jetzt als neues Mitglied in der Raibe irgendwie aufschlage und sage, Schönen guten Tag, ich hab dir die super Idee, ich möchte irgendwie, keine Ahnung, einen ASCII gründen oder einen ganz großen Internet- Hosting-Provider oder sonst irgendwas und sag, ich brauch halt ein riesiges Netzwerk von IPv4-Adressen, und die sagen, dass du uns leid, die Community hat beschlossen, dass du nur noch ein kleines Scheibchen bekommst.
Und dann stehst du da.
Und dann gibt's natürlich vier Geweine, sag ich mal, aber dann gibt's Vorschläge, dass man diese Vergabelichtlinien doch bitte ändern soll. Also jeder, da kommt wieder die Allgemeinheit rein. Jeder, der zu Hause ist, der einen Internet-Anschluss hat und eine E-Mail-Adresse hat, kann sich aus diesen Mailing-Listen abonnieren und kann Änderungsvorschläge einbringen. Das machen auch immer mal wieder welche. Also da gibt es aktuell drei Vorschläge, die bearbeitet werden und dann wird darüber diskutiert. Das kann halt jeder machen, aber ja, oftmals wird dann die Mehrheit dann, ne, wir lassen das so wie es ist. Also das handfesten Streit gibt es ja nicht. Es gibt immer wieder Leute, die schlagen immer wieder das Gleiche vor, wobei der Vorschlag schon drei Mal abgelehnt wurde, aber das darf man halt machen.
Und was genau machst du da? Bist du da mit Mitglied oder interessierst du dich nur dafür?
Ich komme tatsächlich aus dem CCT-Umsale, bin aber beruflich dabei, dass ich in Firmen gearbeitet habe und arbeite, die, ich sag mal, Mitgliedsleute überreibt sind und versuche halt, ja, ein bisschen die Interessen dieser Firma auch zu vertreten. Dazu gibt es zum Beispiel zweimal im Jahr das Ride-Meeting. Da kann jeder hinfahren, der möchte. Also man muss da nicht Mitglied für sein, nicht wieder bei ETS. Man dachte einfach, hey, da ist jetzt jetzt mal, das nächste Ride-Meeting ist im Mai in Kopenhagen zum Beispiel, dann kann man sagen, okay, ich trage irgendwie meine Gebühr, meine Eintrittskarte, die, ich glaub, 300 Euro oder was die ist und zwei mal Hotel und mal einen Zug oder mal einen Zug dahin. Dann kann ich dahin fahren und kann mich mit den Leuten zusammenwitten und diskutieren. Also auch mit den Working Groups und anderen Leuten, die da rumlaufen. Und das mach ich unter anderem. Also ich besuchte so Ride-Meeting oder ich, so eine Firma, die Mitglied wird oder eine Organisation, es mussten gerne Firma sein. Das nennt sich dann, da haben wir die nächste Abkürzung, LIR, Local Internet Registry. Das sind sozusagen die Mitglieder dieses Ride-Vereins.
Mein Teil ist, ich bin Mitarbeiter in so einer LIR, treu das Netzwerk da oder man baut halt, ich hab auch schon fünf Begleiter, die sich da beworben haben und Mitglied geworden sind.
Aber ansonsten ist es halt, ich verfolge das, ich nehm daran teil, ich diskutiere mit den Leuten.
Es ist eine große Gemeinschaft.
Wird man da nicht wahnsinnig?
Nee, es ist eigentlich sehr angenehm, weil, wie in der ersten Stunde schon gehört, es ist halt frei von politischen Zwingen.
Zumindest für mich gefühlt.
Die Leute sind intelligent, die machen Spaß, das gibt Lust in den Menschen. Man kann mit denen auch ganz nett mal ein Bierchen trinken gehen und nächsten Tag kann man sich trotzdem angeregt über Adressvergabe zum Beispiel unterhalten.
Sehr zivil.
Das ist auch ähnlich wie beim IOTF. Es gibt halt immer unterschiedliche Working Groups, die sich dann wieder treffen, weil das natürlich alles gleichzeitig zu viel wäre. Es ist tatsächlich, kann ich auch bestätigen, eine extrem angenehme Community wieder für Studenten. Zum Beispiel kostet das nur 50 Euro die gesamte Woche mit Vollverpflegung und Willkommenspaket.
Bei IOTF ist es über und zu 150 Dollar. Ich hab's inzwischen nochmal nachgeguckt.
Die versuchen auch wirklich die Einstiegshürden auch finanziell so niedrig wie möglich zu halten. Aber allein schon das Mittagsbuffet an fünf Tagen ist da eigentlich mehr wert als diese 50 Euro, die man da zahlt.
Sollte man als Informatikstudent mal hinfahren? Also jetzt egal, ob man sich dann später dafür wirklich so krass interessiert, am einen das Magazin zu haben oder sagt dir so, nee, lieber nicht da rumhängen und Plätze wegnehmen?
Also wenn man sich für die Technik oder für das Internet, wie das funktioniert, wie das zusammenhängt, interessiert, ist das auf jeden Fall eine Reise wert, denke ich schon.
Ja, auch für IOTF. Die sind übrigens auch immer mal wieder woanders. Jetzt, wie gesagt, das nächste in Kopenhagen. Die machen zwei nur im Jahr. ITF macht ja drei. Reib macht zwei im Jahr. Eins immer in Amsterdam, in ihrem Stammsitz. Und das zweite halt woanders, in Europa oder Nahost oder wo auch immer sie halt vertreten sind.
Vielleicht noch was anmerkenswert, genau wie bei ITF, für die Leute, die jetzt sagen, ich kann mir das nicht leisten, nicht interessiert das. Aber man kann an diesen Diskussionen, wie gesagt, auch per Mating teilnehmen. Oder es wird alt auch teilweise gespeakt.
Ich kann auch mal was sagen, vielleicht wenn jetzt nicht jeder Hörer da gleich hinrennt, es gibt da nicht ernsthafte Einlasskontrollen. Da steht nicht vor jeder Working Group ein Typ mit Sonnenbrille und schwarzen Anzug und einer Knarre im Sacko, der kontrolliert, ob du da dein Ticket um den Hals hast. Das heißt, man kann auch einfach mal so hintapsen. Man darf nicht vergessen, die meisten kennen dich auch noch.
Das ist ein sehr großes Vertrauenverhältnis. Wenn da jetzt einer irgendwie aufschläuft, ich glaube, da wird kein großes Drama geben. Wenn da nicht das ganze Befehle her ist, glaube ich.
Dann werden die Internetnummernvergeber aber sehr eigen. Was ich mich gerade frage ist, auch weil es so kompliziert ist zu erklären hier, wir haben ja jetzt nicht allzu wenig Zeit, diese Gremien funktionieren aber in sich selber und die betreiben keine Art von Öffentlichkeitsarbeit. Oder das bleibt schon alles in dieser Technik?
Nee, das ist alles offen. Du kannst das alles nachlesen. Aber sie machen keine Werbung dafür.
Genau, das meine ich. Das Angebot ist sozusagen, jeder kann, wenn er nur klug genug ist oder genug weiß. Aber es ist nicht so, dass aktiv darum geworben wird, dass auch andere Menschen das verstehen, die nicht das ganze Wissen haben. Also sowas wie, keine Ahnung, EFF machen oder halt CCC. Dass man das Thema auch immer nach außen trägt und sagt, so hier, das Thema ist wichtig.
Beim RIPE gibt es zum Beispiel solche Sachen, dass man schon versucht, Studenten zu gewinnen, da mitzuarbeiten. Es gibt irgendwelche Hackathons, die dann so Messdaten, die da erfasst werden, zum Beispiel visualisieren sollen, also Programmierwettbewerbe. Wo man sich dafür qualifiziert hat, auch durchaus die Anreise zum RIPE-Meeting bezahlt wird und auch der Aufenthalt in Amsterdam bei RIPE, um an diesem Ding teilzunehmen. Sofern versucht man schon ja so ein bisschen, auch eine neue Generation natürlich reinzubekommen und da Werbung für zu machen, das bekannt zu machen. Aber es ist jetzt nicht so, dass das RIPE oder andere Organisationen da jetzt Werbebroschüren drucken und verschicken, dass man da Mitglied werden muss, weil es eine technische Notwendigkeit ist, zum Beispiel MIP-Adressen zu bekommen. Da muss man sowieso Mitglied werden.
Ich meine gar nicht mal, dass man Mitglied wird, sondern einfach, dass auf eine allgemeinverständliche Art kommuniziert wird, was da passiert.
Also es gibt bei ITF auch so Stipendiengeschichten. Die werden aber eben auch nur in einer Research Community, also im universitären Umfeld werden die auch publiziert und sowas gemacht. Aber keine dieser Organisationen hat zum Beispiel Geld, um bei großen Medien oder sonst irgendwas vorstellig zu werden oder eine PR-Agentur zu bezahlen, damit sie abends in der Tagesschau auftauchen.
Nee, das meine ich alles nicht. Aber es würde ja reichen, wenn auf deren Website zu sagen, es gibt hier, keine Ahnung, Nachrichten für Noob sozusagen. Also der Punkt ist, warum ich das gerade frage, es gibt dieses Gremium und da kann zwar theoretisch jeder hin, aber es findet halt innerhalb dieser Technikgemeinde statt. Das heißt also, wir als normale User müssen euch darauf verlassen, dass ihr, ich mache jetzt mal die Grenzen ein bisschen plakativ, dass ihr da keinen Scheiß baut.
Es wird ja nicht jeden zum Hirnchirurgenkrankreis gehen und sagen, erklär mir das mal ganz einfach.
Also sicherlich wird das versucht. Nee, aber da gibt es einen Ärztekammer und da gibt es irgendwann den Staat und dann gibt es Gesetze und sowas. Das wird halt alles irgendwie geregelt.
Die Ärztekammer ist viel geheimnisvoller als REIB und ITF zusammen.
Vielleicht, aber es gibt ja sozusagen Gesetze.
Okay, das vergleiche ich mit dir. Ja, also ich sage mal so, die Erfahrung, die ich jetzt mit der REIB zum Beispiel habe, ist, wenn werden, wo du jetzt schon gesagt hast, es zwingt nur, wenn ich manchmal einfach da Mitglied zu werden, wenn ich gewisse Dinge im Internet machen möchte. Und da zum Beispiel machen die schon, dass sie, es gibt so, ich sag mal, Einsteigerkurse für bestimmte Thematiken bereitgetreffend. Die haben so eine hübsche Datenbank, wo alle möglichen Informationen zu verschiedenen IP-Adressen, Adressblöcken oder sonstigen Nummern, die die halt vergeben, hinterlegt sind.
Und da scheitern ganz viele auch da dran, solche Dinge zu bedienen.
Da gehen die wie schonmühe an die Mitglieder, kommunizieren die schon hier, wir machen wieder einen Workshop, kannst kostenlos vorbeikommen und nimm mal daran teil.
Die setzen sich auch mit dir hin und gehen das eine Stunde mit dir zusammen durch, wenn du es nicht verstanden hast.
Das tun sie schon.
Es gibt halt viele, die müssen da Mitglied sein, weil die Firma jetzt irgendwas im Internet machen will, aber die wissen gar nicht genau so richtig, wie es funktioniert.
Und für die gibt es schon so ein bisschen Schulung, aber halt nicht, dass sie irgendwie rausgehen und irgendwie ein Handbook schreiben.
Also es ist ja auch nicht so, dass du als Endanwender unbedingt Kontakt direkt mit dem RIPE hast, weil zu Hause bekommst du eine IP-Adresse eben von deinem Provider automatisch zugewiesen und hast eigentlich gar keinen Kontakt in diese technischen Untiefen da.
Ja klar, die Frage ist halt, wie lange das gut geht. Aber das geht gut.
Du kannst dich, wie gesagt, die verheimlichen nichts. Du kannst einfach danach googeln. Du findest die auch. Die stehen auch beide Organisationen stehen. Google ganz oben. Aber du musst halt danach suchen. Sie drängen sich dir nicht auf. Aber das tut die Ärztekammer auch nicht.
Ich weiß nicht, ob diese Ärztekammer vielleicht nicht doch ein bisschen hängt. Na gut, Alex, dir auf jeden Fall vielen Dank für die vielen Erklärungen. Und viel Spaß beim nächsten RIPEen. Nennt man das so? Dann viel Spaß beim Besuch des nächsten RIPE-Meetings. Danke, bis dann. Tschüss. Jetzt haben wir ja auf einer abstrakten Ebene, aber ich glaube, das ist heute nicht die abstrakte Ebene. Wir haben jetzt geklärt, wer sich darum kümmert, dass alle Teilnehmer des Internets dieselbe Sprache sprechen. Wir haben erklärt, wer sich darum kümmert, dass jeder Teilnehmer im Internet eine Nummer hat, unter der er erreicht werden kann. Und müssen dann noch klären, dass jeder Teilnehmer im Internet einen Namen hat, damit man sich diese komischen Nummern nicht merken muss. Das machen wir nachher. Jetzt haben wir erstmal noch eine Musik von Broke For Free und die heißt Mel's Parade. Ich hoffe, sie läuft durch.
P Der Hip Hop Hochrader spielt auf.
Präsentiert von Fritz. Mit Emily Ulbricht. Die Große Koalition hat ihren Streit um Änderungen beim Asylrecht beendet. SPD-Chef Garbgel sagte am Abend nach einem Treffen mit Bundeskanzlerin Merkel und dem CSU-Vorsitzenden Seehofer, dass strittige Punkte geklärt wurden. Dazu gehört, dass bei nicht unmittelbar verfolgten Flüchtlingen der Familiennachzug für zwei Jahre ausgesetzt wird. Gerade bespricht die Kanzlerin Einzelheiten mit den Länderchefs. Elektronische Zigaretten und E-Schischas dürfen in Zukunft nicht mehr an unter 18-Jährige verkauft werden. Mit der Entscheidung schloss der Bundestag am Abend eine Gesetzeslücke. Bisher waren elektronische Zigaretten vom Verkaufsverbot an Jugendliche ausgenommen, weil sie keinen Tabak enthalten. Experten waren jedoch vor den gefährlichen Inhaltsstoffen. Verbraucherschutzminister Schmidt sagte, Rauchen sei nicht harmlos, auch wenn es nach Kaugummischmecke oder nach Melone rieche. Die geplanten Flüchtlingsunterkünfte auf dem Tempelhofer Feld in Berlin können gebaut werden. Eigentlich sind Bauten dort verboten, aber das Abgeordnetenhaus hat das durch einen Volksentscheid entstandene Gesetz dazu heute geändert. Der Senat will an der Nordwestseite des Feldes bis zu 7.000 Flüchtlinge unterbringen, in Hallen oder Containern.
Die Opposition ist dagegen.
Berlin bekommt ein eigenständiges Landesamt für Flüchtlingsangelegenheiten. Das hat das Abgeordnetenhaus beschlossen. Wann es losgeht, wie viel Personal dort arbeiten soll und was genau das Konzept des neuen Landesamtes ist, ist noch unklar. Die neue Behörde wird aus dem bisherigen Landesamt für Gesundheit und Soziales ausgegliedert. Das Lagiso wird kritisiert, es sei überfordert. Flüchtlinge würden oft tagelang draußen warten und würden schlecht betreut. Das Wetter Mit den aktuellen Temperaturen in Berlin Triebdose sind es 0 Grad und in Charlottenburg 5 Grad, in Flüthigsfelde und Frankfurt an der Oder melden 2 Grad, in Wittstock-Dosse 3 Grad und in Joachimsthal sind es 4 Grad. In der Nacht bleibt es wolkenlos und weitgehend trocken und die Temperaturen gehen runter auf plus 2 bis minus 2 Grad. Morgen ist es im Norden von Brandenburg etwas wolkiger, im Süden ist es freundlicher und trocken und das Ganze bei Höchstwerten zwischen 8 und 11 Grad. Da hab ich nur eine Meldung aus Berlin und zwar aus Moabit. Nach einem Wasserrohrbruch ist die Fennstraße in Höhe Tegeler Straße weiterhin in beiden Richtungen gesperrt. Die Busse der Linie M27 fahren bereits wieder durch. Da wo es geht, euch eine gute Fahrt.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBB. Und wenn ihr eine Frage oder Kritik oder Lob oder ein schönes Foto, Video oder eine Sprachnachricht oder einfach mal Grüße ins Fritz-Studio schicken wollt, dann macht das doch. Und schon seid ihr mittendrin und im Radio mit der Studio Message in eurer Fritz-App.
Tschüss Heute Chaos Radio im Blue Moon mit mir, Markus Richter und den Gästen vom Chaos Computer Club oder dem näheren Umfeld. Zum Beispiel Mutag, Salon Guten Tag.
Abend.
Und Clemens, Salon Guten Tag.
Guten Abend.
Und es geht heute darum zu erklären, wie das Internet, nicht wie das Internet funktioniert, sondern wer dafür sorgt, dass das Internet funktioniert. Und das ist gar nicht so einfach, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Das ist eher kompliziert. Wir haben schon gelernt in den letzten anderthalb Stunden, dass es ein Organ gibt, das heißt IETF. Und das sorgt dafür, dass die Teilnehmer des Internets, also die verschiedenen Maschinen, dieselbe Sprache sprechen, nur dieselben Sprachen. Es gibt ein Gremium, das dafür sorgt, dass jeder eine Nummer bekommt im Internet, damit er auch erreichbar ist. Und damit wir uns nicht diese Nummern merken müssen, sondern einfach Namen in unsere Browser und sonstigen Kommunikationsprogramme eingeben können, gibt es ein weiteres Gremium. Das sind längst nicht alle, aber wir schaffen heute einfach nicht alle. Wir beschäftigen uns also jetzt mit dem?
Mit den NICs, mit den Network Information Centers.
Hört sich gut an. Habe ich auch schon mal gehört, nämlich DENIC.
Genau, DENIC sind die Leute, die in Deutschland alles verwalten, was auf punkt.de endet im Browser. Das heißt sowas wie fritz.de.
Und die sozusagen, wie ist das eigentlich? Da muss, also wenn ich eine Webseite, ich habe, ich habe ein paar Webseite, egal, ich bin einer von Leuten, die immer eine neue URL kaufen, weil sie eine fesche Idee haben.
Das nennt sich Horder.
Und wenn es eine DE-Domain ist, dann wird immer eine Adresse da eingetragen. Was ist die DENIC? Ist es ein Verein, ist es eine Firma, ist es eine staatliche Stelle?
Die DENIC ist eine Genossenschaft. Genau, das heißt dein Provider ist wahrscheinlich, ist mit hoher Wahrscheinlichkeit Mitglied in der DENIC, in dieser Genossenschaft und ist damit in der Lage, DE-Domains zu registrieren in deinem Namen. Das heißt, du kannst die beauftragen, für dich diese DE-Domain auf deinen Namen da registrieren zu lassen.
Okay, und was passiert dann, wenn das passiert? Was machen die da eigentlich?
Die gucken erstmal natürlich, ob die frei ist. Und sofern sie dann frei ist, wird sie über den in der Datenbank eingetragen. Und ab dem Moment werden alle Anfragen, die für eine Punkt-DE-Domain, also für deine Punkt-DE-Domain, an die DENIC Name Server gestellt werden, weitergeleitet an die dafür zuständigen Name Server. Von deinem Provider oder deinem eigenen. Das heißt, es gibt Server im Internet, die übersetzen von diesen Namen in diese Adressen. Also in die IP-Adressen, die wir ja vorhin schon hatten. Und wenn wir jetzt so etwas wie fritz.de nehmen, dann sieht man halt, das endet auf Punkt.de. Das heißt, ich gucke erstmal, welche Name Server sind denn für Punkt.de zuständig. Und das sind dann die, die die DENIC betreibt. Und dann fragt man einen von denen, wer ist denn für fritz.de zuständig? Und dann sagt einem ein DENIC Name Server, geh doch mal hier zu diesem Name Server hin und frag den, wie die IP-Adresse von fritz.de oder www.fritz.de ist. Und dann kann man eben mit dieser IP-Adresse Kontakt aufnehmen und die Webseite abrufen.
Und warum brauchen wir dazu eine extra Genossenschaft? Die kümmert sich wirklich nur um diese Vergabe. Also schreibt in eine lange Liste rein, hierzu IP-Adresse so und so gehört diese Adresse.
Sie betreibt eine relativ aufwendige Infrastruktur, um sicherzustellen, dass das auch klappt. Es gibt nämlich sehr, sehr viele Domains, die millionenfach am Tag vielleicht sogar milliardenfach abgefragt werden und die Infrastruktur dafür zu betreiben, damit das auch funktioniert. Die DE-Zone, wie wir das nennen, oder Top-Level-Domain ist mit eine der größten in der Welt, nach so.com und so, aber wir stehen relativ weit oben in dieser Hitliste. Und da sind, wie gesagt, sehr viele Domains und es gibt sehr, sehr viele Anfragen. Und die betreiben sogenannte Name-Server. Das sind Rechner, die auch teuer sind, die man erst mal kaufen und betreiben und warten muss. Und davon auch relativ viele, die auf der ganzen Welt verteilt sind, die dafür sorgen, dass wenn jemand fritz.de ein tippt, auch in Südamerika, dass er eine ordentliche Antwort dafür bekommt, eine IP-Adresse, wo er in der Browser drauf zugreifen kann.
Und wer bezahlt das alles?
Die Genossenschaft. So funktioniert das. Die Leute, die sozusagen davon profitieren, dass sie diese Domains machen, nämlich diese Provider, die sie dir vergeben oder verkaufen, du musst dir was für deine Domains bezahlen. Die schmeißen halt alle Geld in einen Topf, in diesen Genossenschaftstopf. Und aus diesem Topf bedient sich sozusagen das DE-NIC und finanziert seine Infrastruktur.
Jetzt hab ich den Verdacht bei den anderen beiden Dingen, da hieß es ja immer, naja, das ist alles irgendwie total unpolitisch und eigentlich wollen ja alle nur das Gute und so weiter und so fort. Und jetzt ist ja so, Adressvergabe im Internet ist ja nicht ganz ohne. Also ein Beispiel, was mir da einfällt ist, ich hab irgendwann mal gehört, zwei buchstabige Domains sind eigentlich nicht zulässig.
Zwei buchstabige Top-Level-Domains. Also wenn sie ganz rechts stehen.
Also auch in Deutschland. In Deutschland waren die lange nicht... Die DENIG-Vergaberichtlinien haben halt lange festgelegt, dass man so zwei buchstabige Domains, so ab.de oder cd.de nicht vergeben, also nicht registrieren kann, um z.B. Markenstreitigkeiten zu verhindern. Weil halt klar ist, bei zwei Buchstaben habe ich nicht so viele davon. D.h. es wird nämlich einen Run darauf geben. Und was halt jetzt da reinspielt ist, dass die DENIG natürlich eine deutsche Genossenschaft ist. die untersteht natürlich komplett deutschem Recht. Das will man ja eigentlich auch so als ländertopleveldomain.de. Und es gab dann einen, jetzt auch in letzter Zeit durch die Medien gegangenen Automobilhersteller aus Deutschland, der gerne seinen Markennamen unter der.de-Domain eingetragen hätte, nämlich vw.de. Und die DENIG hat gesagt, na unsere Vergaberichtlinien sagen, aber geht nicht. Sucht ihr auch was anderes Schönes raus. Und dann sind die vor Gericht gezogen und haben Recht bekommen. Und damit dann es halt eben nicht nur so eine Einzelfallentscheidung ist, hat die DENIG in dem Moment dann gesagt, gut, wenn die Gerichte jetzt entscheiden, wir müssen das VW erlauben, dann erlauben wir das jetzt halt einfach allen.
Man muss das auch unter dem Aspekt betrachten, dass es schon vor dieser Vergaberichtlinie schon zwei Buchstabe-Domains gab. Nämlich z.B. CT für die Computerzeitschrift oder DB für die Deutsche Bahn. Die hatten ihre DE-Domains schon beantragt und auch bekommen, bevor sozusagen diese Spielregeln mit, wir vergeben keine zweistelligen, dann ein Kraftgrad. Das muss man natürlich auch mal sagen. Sowas gibt es auch immer noch. So Legacy-Geschichten. Gibt es zumindest auch bei IP-Adressen. Gibt zum Beispiel IP-Adressen, die nicht vom Raib vergeben wurden. Auch von keinem, von keiner anderen. Von einer der Vorläufer-Organisationen. Oder noch von dem Ur-Opa von der ganzen Geschichte, einem Knaben namens John Postel, der der übrigens sehr ähnlich sieht. Das war ein Forscher in den USA, der ganz so an Internet-Anfangszeiten, derjenige war, der die IP-Adressen vergeben hat. Den konnte man anrufen oder eine E-Mail schreiben oder einen Brief und sagen, hallo, ich brauch mal IP-Adressen. Und hat der zurückgeschrieben, ja, hier nimm doch die Adressen. Hat sie dir da für einen Zettel geschrieben oder eine Datei rein und dann war gut. So funktionierte das.
Okay. Aber zurück zum...
Die gibt's immer noch, wollte ich nur sagen, die Adressen.
Zurück zum Nick. Also in DE ist es so geklärt, dass es halt diese eine Genossenschaft hat. Jetzt frage ich mich ja erstmal, wer hat denn der DENIC überhaupt das übertragen? Also wer hat denn die Macht zu sagen, okay, du bist der, der sich um die DE-Adressen kümmert?
Tja, das hat sich wieder mal so einfach ergeben aus der Zeit heraus, wo das Internet noch nicht staatlich, keine Aufmerksamkeit hatte staatlich. Inzwischen gibt es diverse Organisationen, auch zum Beispiel solche Läden, die sich sonst um sowas kümmern, wie zum Beispiel unsere Bundesnetzagentur, die sich um die Vergabe von Telefondummern oder Vorwahlen oder sowas kümmert, die da sehr, sehr gerne ihre Finger drin hätten. Aber nun ist der Zug abgefahren und haben halt seit Jahrzehnten diese privaten Organisationen oder diese Genossenschaften oder diese halböffentlichen Organisationen gemacht. Und da ist jetzt nicht mehr so leicht dran kommen.
Eine schöne Sache als Conor Truss dazu ist zum Beispiel Punkt EU. Also wer sich so mit der EU so ein bisschen auskennt, wird sich wahrscheinlich jetzt schon denken, wie das gelaufen ist. Weil die EU dachte sich, wir wollen auch für ganz Europa einen Top-Level-Domain Punkt EU haben und hat dann eben eine EU-Verordnung 2002 verabschiedet, dass das jetzt so sein soll. Und hat dann eben über einige Jahre kam es dann dazu, dass die sogenannte EURIT entstanden ist, die dann für die Punkt-EU-Top-Level-Domain die ganzen Domains verwaltet. Und dann gab es dann irgendwie auch noch Stress mit einer Organisation. Und zwar war das die ICANN.
Wer ist das jetzt schon wieder?
Ja, die ICANN ist jetzt der aktuelle Nachfolger von den Leuten, die über den Namensraum wachen. Allerdings so ein bisschen, naja, okay, lass mal mal. Es gibt auch eine Interaktion mit der ITF.
Warte mal, also die ICANN sozusagen, das sind dann schon die, die auch gesagt haben, okay, ihr dürft euch um die DE kümmern, oder wie? Das sind die, die quasi das ganze Internet verwalten.
DE gab es schon, bevor es ICANN gab. Das muss man als sozusagen altes Zeug sagen. Aber es gibt ja jetzt Top-Level-Domains wie zum Beispiel Punkt Volkswagen oder Punkt Berlin.
Oder Punkt ADAC.
Oder Punkt ADAC. Und diese Namen, die wurden von ICANN vergeben. Und ICANN ist eine, hatte ich vorhin schon mal erwähnt, ist auch so eine Geschichte, so die US Department of Commerce hatte da mal seine fingerlange Zeit drin. Ist auch eine sehr umstrittene Organisation. Und die verkaufen jetzt sozusagen diese Top-Level-Domains. Kann man übrigens nur mal nebenbei sagen, interessant, allein sich um eine solche zu bewerben, muss man diverses Papierkram ausfüllen und einen Application-Fee von 185.000 Dollar raus tun. Das heißt, der ADAC hat seine Mitgliedsgelder ganz toll angelegt, indem er sich allein, um sich für Punkt ADAC zu bewerben, einfach mal 185.000 Dollar bei der ICANN auf den Tisch gelegt hat.
Bewerben heißt, der kriegt die dann nicht automatisch.
Nein, du kriegst es nicht garantiert. Es kann ja noch jemand anders geben, der auch ADAC haben will.
Der auch so viel Geld dafür bezahlt hat, sich zu bewerben.
Nur einer von denen kriegt es dann.
Verbrecher. Kapitalisten. Das verwirrt mich jetzt aber hoch gerade sozusagen. Dass einerseits die DE-Domänen sozusagen so, ja das war halt schon immer so und deswegen machen wir es so. Und andererseits jetzt eine Firma anscheinend über den ganzen Rest des Internets. Also wer gibt denn denen die Macht, dass sie jetzt jede neue Top-Level-Domänen bestimmen können?
Das ist die Interaktion, die ich eben erwähnte, mit ITF. ITF hat gesagt, pass auf, lieber iCAN, ihr könnt alles möglich verkaufen, außer folgende. Da haben wir den Finger drauf. Zum Beispiel die zwei Buchstabigen wieder. Das sind mich für diese Länder Top-Level-Domains. Für DE, für Deutschland und NL, für Niederland und so weiter und so fort. Da haben sie gesagt, iCAN Finger weg. Die gehören den jeweiligen Länder-Registries. Oder welchen Organisation auch mal in dem Land, der dafür zuständig ist. Und es gibt auch noch andere Sachen, die von der ITF, ich sag jetzt mal, gesperrt sind, die iCAN nicht verkaufen kann. Aber den Rest verkauft, nee, verkauft ist das falsche Wort, verleiht. Verleiht iCAN.
Ja, das verstehe ich trotzdem nicht, wie sie sagen, wieso sie sich das Recht nehmen können. Also, warum, bzw. warum dann nicht andere Leute aufstehen und sagen, ne, das ist doch Quatsch, wir wollen das anders.
iCAN ist wieder keine Firma. iCAN ist sowas wieder wie eine Stiftung oder Genossenschaft, nur auf internationale Ebene und unterliegt amerikanischen Recht und so weiter.
Ja, aber komm, da muss doch aber irgend einer extrem dran profitieren, wenn man sozusagen 185.000 Dollar...
Wissen wir, wissen wir? Anwaltsfirmen. Diese ganze Geschichte mit dem ganzen Internet, da es da herkommt und das steht, extrem amerikanisch im Recht. Das heißt, die ganzen Copyright-Themen, die da diskutiert werden, da verklagt ja jeder jeden zu jeder Zeit andauernd. Und deswegen ist der Aufwand auch so hoch. Wenn du jetzt mit irgendeinem Namen ankommst, wie Punkt Fritz oder sowas, dann könnte es ja zum Beispiel sein, dass hier in Deutschland dich schon die Firma AVM verklagt, weil sie sagt, wir haben aber hier ein Produkt, das heißt Fricks. Und dann gibt es irgendwelche Dänen, die sagen, wir haben aber hier eine Brause, die heißt Fritz oder was weiß ich. Und allein um diese legalen Dispute oder sowas auch nur einigermaßen in Zorn zu halten, beschäftigen die Herrscher von Anwälten und die saugen die ganze Kohle auf.
Und das merkt man auch schon daran, wie so eine Top-Level-Domain in eine neue eingeführt wird. Also sowas wie Punkt Shoes oder Punkt EU, die werden nicht einfach so freigeschaltet, sondern wenn man sich da registrieren möchte, wenn die neu auf den Markt kommen, gibt es eine Sunrise-Periode, wo jeder, der irgendwelche Markenrechtsansprüche hat, sich erst mal melden kann und sagen kann, die Domain aber bitte sperren, weil da hab ich meinen Markenschutz drauf, oder ich möchte die aber für mich registrieren. Und erst wenn das vorbei ist, dann kann man sich insgesamt bewerben. Und das ist eigentlich nur eine riesengroße Geldschneiderei, weil nämlich alle denken, dass sie jetzt auch auf diesen ganzen neuen Top-Level-Domains sich ihre Domains registrieren müssen. So ein Schuhhändler zum Beispiel, der denkt sich, oh Mist, jetzt gibt es Punkt Schuhe. Damit ich jetzt keinen Nachteil habe, muss ich da aber auch jetzt für 80 Euro in meine Punkt Schuhe-Domain registrieren. Oder irgendwelche Restaurants haben jetzt den Zugzwang, es gibt jetzt Punkt Restaurant als Top-Level-Domain. Ich muss jetzt ganz dringend als Berliner Restaurant auch irgendwie Müller.Restaurant registrieren, damit die Leute mich da in dieser Restaurant-Domain trobbeln.
Und ich muss auch Restaurant Müller.Berlin.
Genau, Punkt Berlin natürlich auch und so weiter.
Das absurdeste Beispiel aus dem deutschen Sprachraum, der letzten Jahre war Punkt Kinder. Kannst du mal überlegen, wer das registriert hat.
Ferrero.
Ja, genau.
Das ist tatsächlich zu sagen, da hab ich mich auch gefragt, wie das geht. Also vor wem haben die wie durchgesetzt, dass jetzt Kinder sozusagen eine Top-Level-Lumine für den Hersteller, also ein Markenname ist und nicht das deutsche Wort.
Mussten sie nicht durchsetzen, sind halt hingegangen zu iKen, haben gesagt, hallo, hier habt ihr 185.000 Dollar, wir hätten das gerne. Und dann haben die geprüft und gemacht und getan. Und kein anderer hat den Finger gewoben, hat gesagt, das will aber ich haben. Es gab diverse, die gesagt haben, das ist aber blöd, weil es ein normales deutsches Wort, das kann man doch nicht einfach irgendeiner Firma geben. Aber das hast du ja auch mit anderen Dingen, wo sich Firmen einfach normale deutsche Worte nehmen als Produktname oder so. Und da dem keiner widersprochen hat lange Zeit, haben sie den Ding halt eben vergeben. Fertig.
Übrigens auch nicht die deutsche Bundesregierung, die da irgendwie mal gefragt wurde.
Nö.
Das ist doch alles fürchterlich. Warum sind wir denn so depressiv am Ende?
Das sind die Abgründe. Wir hätten den Abgrund zum Anfang machen müssen, dann hätten wir jetzt die hübscheren Sachen verrechnen.
Was ich mich jetzt aber frage, wird schon an so einer Art Alternativsystem für diese Namensvergabe gearbeitet, damit man dem ein Stift geschlagen hat?
Ja, gab es auch schon lange.
Was dann? Wie denn?
Es gibt so verschiedene Leute, die einen alternativen Route Tree oder DNS Route Tree betreiben, also einen alternativen Namensraum betreiben wollen. Es gibt auch Leute, die das immer wieder machen. Das Problem ist, da hast du als normaler Benutzer nichts davon, weil die Systeme, so wie sie ausgeliefert werden, egal ob von Microsoft, Apple oder sonst wem, kommen von Hause erst mal eingestellt mit dem Zugriff auf den normalen Namensraum, damit auch das passiert, was man erwartet, was passiert. Du rennst halt auf der Straße rum, siehst ein Schild, da steht halt fritz.de drauf, zückst dein Handy, tippst es ein, erwartest, dass du dann auch bei Fritz ankommst. Weil wenn es jetzt einen alternativen Namensraum gäbe, müsstest du jetzt versuchen, auch dort wieder deinen Namen zu registrieren oder reinzukriegen. Sonst würde das da wieder nicht funktionieren. Die Technik lässt dazu, dass man einfach alternative Namensräume macht und da auch eigene Nameserver-Strukturen macht. Aber solange die keiner benutzt, hat es halt keinen Sinn. Kennst du diese Telefonbücher, die so rausgegeben werden von irgendwelchen alternativen Adressbuchverlagen? Gab es früher mal, ich weiß nicht, ob es sie immer noch gibt, die dich dann anschreiben, sagen, ja, kommen sie doch in unser tolles, aber wenn keiner diese Telefonbücher liest, dann ist es auch egal.
Ach ja, man könnte sagen, bei den Domains ist es noch irgendwie verkraftbar, weil es ja noch die Länder-Domains gibt, wo man halt, also irgendeine Webseite wird man schon kriegen. Das ist dann halt vielleicht nicht die schönste, aber irgendeine wird schon irgendwie am Start sein. Wie ist denn das jetzt, es gibt jetzt, sagen wir, dieses System, das ist auch historisch alles gewachsen, dass es halt diese ganzen Gremien gibt, die sich selber kümmern. Wird sich das in Zukunft mal irgendwie ändern? Also wenn man so ein bisschen guckt, kann ich mir vorstellen, dass einerseits schon Staaten irgendwie also ein langanhaltendes und auch langfristiges Interesse daran haben, natürlich mal ein bisschen mehr Kontrolle zu kriegen. Und andererseits, wenn man sich so ein bisschen Science-Fiction durchliest, dann gibt es immer sozusagen so Ideen von so einem weltweit umspannenden Netz, was dann komplett von Firmen kontrolliert wird. Wie wird das in Zukunft aussehen mit den Gremien, die unser Internet irgendwie kontrollieren und standardisieren und beschließen?
Na, ich hoffe, dass es erst mal so bleibt, wie es ist. Sehr konservativ so diese Gremien, weil es eigentlich bisher ziemlich gut funktioniert hat. Wir sehen Diskussionen, die wir jetzt bei dieser ganzen Kryptodebatte hatten, wo die NSA eben in diese Gremien reingegangen ist und bestimmte Algorithmen versucht hat zu ändern in ihrem Sinn, dass sie die knacken können.
Das sagst du jetzt, zehn Minuten vor Senderende. Das sind die NSA in diesen Gremien, Dirnis?
Klar.
Na klar, also jeder kann ja mitmachen, als es auch die NSA denn und die NSA machte auch gute Arbeit, weil sie natürlich Ahnung haben von Krypto-Algorithmen. Aber gleichzeitig versuchen die natürlich auch ein bisschen zu schwächen die Standards, damit sie die besser entschlüsseln können. Das ist natürlich diese Abwägung und die haben schon sehr, sehr viel Gutes da auch getan. Aber in den letzten Jahren hat man gemerkt, dass sie da eben auch nicht so gute Dinge mit reingeschmuggelt haben. Weswegen die natürlich jetzt extrem kritisch begutachtet werden, alles, was die da so eingebracht haben. Das Schöne ist, da das alles so offen ist, kann man jetzt gucken, was hat denn, was haben den Vertreter der NSA in den letzten Jahren alles so vorgeschlagen und kann sich alles das kritisch angucken.
Ja, die anderen Sachen, also der Namensraum, da sind schon die Begehrlichkeiten groß. Weil wer den Namensraum kontrolliert, kann natürlich auch super zensieren. Wenn es jetzt eine staatliche Behörde gibt, die jetzt irgendwann mal DE kontrolliert und wir sagen hier auf Fritz Dinge, die dem Staat nicht mehr gefallen, dann kann man natürlich einfach die Fritz-DE-Domain killen. Und so was. Und das hängt halt schon immer von den Ländern ab. Man sieht auch da Versuche entweder in totalitären Staaten, es ist eh schon längst in staatlicher Hand, aber man sieht auch Versuche eben in anderen Ländern, die so gerade mal wieder auf der Schwelle stehen, dass man auch da an diese Dinger dran langt. Bei anderen Sachen geht es technisch nicht. Sie können nicht einfach irgendwie IP-Adressen vergeben, die ihnen nicht gehören. Das können sie machen, aber das funktioniert dann halt nicht. Auch bei technischen Standards können sie das machen. Das machen zum Beispiel die Chinesen, die machen sehr viel Sachen inhouse, wo sie Sachen machen, die nur in China funktionieren oder Nordkorea zum Beispiel. Die technischen Standards beschließen, die nur in ihrem Land gelten, die auch nur dort implementiert werden. Aber das hilft ihnen halt nicht im weltweiten Internet. Das heißt, da ist es schwierig. Aber bei den Namensräumen sehe ich in der Tat Potenzial, dass da über kurz oder lang gerade staatliche Stellen mal ihre Finger drauf legen.
Und gibt es da eine Gegensstrategie?
Protest, User-Protest, wie es immer so ist. Aber das Interessante ist ja, niemand zwingt da jemanden bei fritz.de. Wenn der DDE-Leute auf den Sack gehen mit ihren Anforderungen, dann gehst du halt, weiß ich, auf die doppelte Domain-Punkt Radio, die halt nicht mehr von der deutschen Regierung kontrolliert wird.
Tatsächlich.
Aber das ist dein Weg aus. Das heißt, du kannst halt eben hingehen, einfach einen anderen Domain nehmen, die unter einer anderen Jurisdiktion steht. Das geht schon.
Wo werdet ihr in Zukunft mitarbeiten?
Ich mach weiter ITF. Ich fahr jetzt im März nach Buenos Aires. Und wenn das ITF, wenn mal so ein RIPE-Meeting mal in der Nähe ist, dann spring ich auch da gerne mal rein.
Woran arbeitest du jetzt konkret beim ITF?
Ich gehöre auch mit zu dem Team, was die Infrastruktur aufbaut. Wenn da so ein Meeting stattfindet, das hält ja kein Kongresszentrum oder kein Hotel aus. Wenn da mal 1500 Leute einfallen, die das Internet nutzen. Und zwar richtig. Das heißt, da schwirren dann mal so 4.000, 5.000 Geräte im WLAN rum. Und das hält kein Hotelnetz aus. Und das sind so Sachen, die ich da zusammen mit anderen Helferleinern aus aller Welt aufbaue.
Ich werde wieder bei den Drive Meetings aufschlagen. Das ist eine ziemlich gute Möglichkeit, um da Leute kennenzulernen. Und so als Wissenschaftler ist es halt ganz praktisch, an den Leuten nahe dran zu sein, um im Austausch zu sein und die nächsten heißen Themen frühzeitig kennenzulernen.
Jetzt bin ich vielleicht jemand, der irgendwie so ein, sagen wir, ein Systemadministrator ist. Und so Web-Server-Administrator schon so ein bisschen Ahnung hat, aber die eben das Ganze, was ja heute so doch ein bisschen zu groß ist. Gibt es da so einen leichten Einstieg rein, dass man irgendwie so oder?
Hingehen.
Ja, hingehen.
Es gibt immer so Einführungsveranstaltungen bei beiden.
Das ist das eine. Und ansonsten gibt es halt oft auch lokale Gruppen. Also in Berlin haben wir irgendwie einen Admin-Stammtisch, den es da irgendwie gibt. Der nennt sich irgendwie FLAB. Es gibt irgendwie FLAB. Das ist so was wie FU und BAR, so eine random Variable, die einfach keine Bedeutung hatten. Die war halt frei die Domain. Natürlich. Also haben wir uns an FLAB.de genannt. Es gibt die Gug, die Germany Unix User Group. Und es gibt so deutschlandweit so was wie die DNOG oder so was. Also ein loser Zusammenschluss von Admins, die da irgendwie im Netzwerkbereich sehr aktiv sind. Und das sind alles Gruppen, die man irgendwie finden kann, wo man Leute treffen kann.
Das heißt also, dass du sagen, dass wenn ich nicht gleich ganz oben einsteigen will, wo ich mich mal langsam rantasten kann.
Und die Leute überschneiden sich auch. Also bei den Admin-Stammtischen findet man Leute, die im Rhype irgendwie aktiv sind und bei denen auch natürlich sowieso. Und das ist alles im Grunde irgendwann eine einzige große Familie. Man trifft irgendwie immer dieselben Gesichter.
Ich danke euch vielmals, dass ihr mir versucht habt und mir und den Hörern und Hörerinnen im vergangenen zwei Stunden versucht habt, zu erklären, wie das mit dem Internet hinter den Kulissen funktioniert. Ich glaube, mir reicht das jetzt. Also ich finde es gut, dass ihr das macht. Und ich glaube aber auch, ich habe jetzt genug davon. Vielen Dank. Das war das Chaosradio. Wir können das nochmal nachhören, falls ihr es nicht genau verstanden habt. Diese eine Stelle würde ich gerne nochmal. Es wird als Podcast erscheinen im Laufe der Nacht auf fritz.de und dann im weiteren Verlauf auch auf chaosradio.ccc.de Dort auch mit Bild, das aufgenommen wurde. Und ansonsten... Nein, nein, das Bild war... Bildklammer hat funktioniert und der Streaming nicht. Es gab kein Live-Bild, aber es gibt auf jeden Fall ein aufgezeichnetes Bild. Also, wenn jetzt nicht noch der Chip abstürzt oder sowas. Außerdem könnt ihr im nächsten Monat mit dabei sein, wenn das Chaos Radio nicht hier bei Fritz passiert, sondern live im Chaos Computer Club Berlin in der Marienstraße 11. Da wird die Sendung auch fast genauso gemacht wie hier. Nur mit dem Unterschied, dass es nicht im Radio läuft, sondern nur in diesem komischen, weltweiten Internet. In zwei Monaten gibt es das dann wieder hier auf Fritz zu hören. Jetzt kommt danach der Nightfly mit Jan Schwarzkamp, der euch mit Musik bewerfen wird. Ich bedanke mich bei Clemens. Und bei Mootox, vielen Dank.
Bitte, bitte.
Und wir hatten nur noch zu sagen, mein Name ist Markus Richter. Lasst euch nicht überwachen und verschlüsselt immer schön eure Backups.